it's really easy for damian lillard
coming off a 30-plus point performance
in that loss against the lakers and
juan lamar you pointed out when he
landed on the foot of a laker didn't
quite move the same the rest of the game
as ball
gets his first bucket of the game damage
charlotte not huge
on the front line as you get a look at
the distance
pretty good up until the shot the blazer
is able to get a
more life-sized matchup mellow with the
hezzy and throwing it down
he will be on a mellow name basis as
well
worldwide mello pump fake draws another
foul count the basket third quarter
nears an end
ball defended by little ball up top to
bridges
negated by the blazers yeah they sniffed
that out that's a play charlotte likes
to run oh mellow's not messing around
anthony pouring it on
eight for eight five of five from three
that ties his season high
21 points and ball for the stuff
lillard attacking bridges steps back
long pass bridges able to come down with
it that's a pinpoint pass
[Applause]
ball no hesitation lamelo ball
29 points for the rookie creates a
little contact
martin little brother ball to his twin
brother and mello
once again swiping at it no whistle